bootstrap is big and it has to be big to
accommodate its impressive array of
features that means that the files that
make up the framework are actually
pretty large this also means that for a
small project like yours you aren't
going to ever need or even use all the
functionality but luckily bootstrap
allows us to pick and choose just the
parts of the framework that we need
making the CSS file that we include with
our project significantly smaller to
customize we'll simply go up to the
customize button in the top menu and
then we'll choose the parts that we need
let's go ahead and start by unchecking
everything for our project we're gonna
need typography grid system and modal's
after we've checked those we'll scroll
down and when we get to the bottom of
the screen we see this compile and
download button I want you to follow the
same steps that we just went through and
click this button what type of file do
you download when you press compile and
download is it a CSS file an HTML file
or a zip file